the tears of a mother worried for her
only child and alone since he was
detained by police nearly eight months
ago
Atika burgum says faisal had gone to the
pharmacy to buy her medicine
when police detained him under special
legislation the police files his faisal
who worked in a shop selling water
purifiers in indian-administered Kashmir
was involved in separatist activities
but why does anybody know if this is not
oppression then what is what have we
done to deserve this
why does a poor widow like me have to go
through such difficult times why am i
subject to so much tyranny
I've been appealing to authorities for
several months to look at this case
twenty-two-year-old faisal is one of
more than seven thousand Kashmiri
detained by the Indian government since
it revoked the Regents autonomy last
year New Delhi has said the detentions
are necessary to maintain order and
prevent violence it now says it's
looking into releasing some of the
prisoners after the Supreme Court asked
the government to prevent the spread of
coronavirus and prisons human rights
groups say the detentions without charge
or trial violate both Indian and
international law and with many courts
now closed the public health emergency
should not be used to bypass
accountability many of them have been
begin simply under you know Wabble
orders and that is the most shocking
part actually there is no written even
document so the chances of being
released of those detainees are
extremely problematic extremely critical
the government has closed all schools in
the disputed Kashmir region they
reopened in February only to be shut
again two weeks later after the first
cases of coronavirus were reported in
the territory battalion party it
definitely has a negative impact on the
children's studies although some schools
in tutorials - but the government didn't
do anything for children studying in
government schools there was also a
complete communications blackout with
landline mobile and Internet services
cut off for months slow speed 2g
internet was only restored last month
but 4G is still
unavailable rights groups are calling
for the full restoration of Internet
services so that people have access to
health information and their loved ones
during the pandemic
I am suffering I want to see him once
but I can't afford to I don't know what
to do many who can afford to have met
their relatives but I can't because I'm
poor I'm struggling just to live how can
I even think of going to meet him Atika
has had one video call with faisal whose
friends are giving him money to get by
but the lockdown means they can no
longer visit her Elisabeth puranam
al-jazeera New Delhi